head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts demanding open source or free
software voting like code like agpl 3 so
at least we can look at the code it
doesn't mean that people can't hack into
it and that that might still be an issue
but at least we know that the machines
are doing what they're supposed to do if
we're going to use those yeah I mean no
serious country no country serious about
democracy would ever use an electronic
voting machine and many don't um because
anything digital could be manipulated
look at Wikipedia look at the internet
we're entire portions of History are now
gone um so I would I mean I would just
demand that we have no electronic voting
machines why would you even want to
worry about that but I would say um that
you don't want to give the other side
credit for being straightforward or
honorable because they're not and so
it's not a question of convincing anyone
the argument against Trump in 20 wasn't
a wall is bad you can't make that
argument the argument was you know he's
a bad person and then we had Co which of
course was the kind of pivotal fact of
that election so I I think you have to
assume if we have another pandemic
pandemic or a war particularly a war
between now and election day that is
either you know an intentional act to
subvert our democracy or it certainly
will be harnessed for that use so I just
wouldn't assume that it's going to come
at you straight and head on you know
what I mean yeah we have to understand
people don't relinquish power peacefully
The Establishment has a lot of power
that they're abusing right now we're
dealing with criminals we're dealing
with individuals that have committed
scops that have committed horrible
atrocities on the people of the world
that have started Wars that have started
literal gene splicing chemical
biological warfare against the people so
we have to understand there's going to
be something that's going to be
happening here that we should be
absolutely paying attention to as we're
dealing with uh essentially a
multi-trillion dollar propaganda machine
but it is being wrecked by posters
and memes it is being destroyed by
individuals speaking truth to it it is
being destroyed by individuals coming
together coalescing and saying enough is
enough of this bull crap I am done my
life has value I am standing up for
myself I am standing up for this country
and that is a danger to The
Establishment that they fear and in that
fear we're dealing with a corner animal
that cornered animal is dangerous and
they could act out in many different
ways and I they're capable of anything
they're capable of something that we
can't even imagine Luke's just cranking
it right up to 11 right when we get
started so I can respect way but uh in
terms of what Tucker was just mentioning
about war I'm hearing a lot of talk
about a potential fullscale war with
Russia as something that could
potentially subvert Us in 2024 well War
Means War Powers for the people waging
the war so these are people who think
only in terms of power acquiring it
prevent VG you from having it so they
see it I mean you see war in terms of
its human cost or maybe its geopolitical
effect they see war in terms of their
own fortunes and their own power so the
second we're out war and there's a long
history of this in the west when war
broke out in 1940 and in England the
government later run by Winston
Churchill our hero put the opposition
party in prison with their families
where they stayed without charges and
that's been you know that's been
epsteined it's gone uh as a fact but
it's that actually happened so don't
underestimate the ability of a
government at War to use its new powers
to crush criminally Crush its opponents
there's a there's a journalist by the
names of name of Steve Baker who is a
contributor to the blaze who has tweeted
that he he was in instructed to turn
himself in tomorrow for charges related
to January 6 this guy you see a picture
of him he's wearing a suit he's got
glasses he looks like your your
quintessential journalist Richie
mcginness who's a friend of ours and
also a journalist who worked for the
caller said this this guy's
unambiguously a journalist and he told
them only a few months ago they'll never
arrest you for this but now they're
doing it so how about no I mean when is
the first person going to stand up and
say this is fake this is political I'm
not submitting I mean I don't know at
some point they're going to force people
to do that everyone in this room
believes in the system grew up in the
system was proud of the system for its
unique fairness globally unique no
system was fairer than ours and that's
the main thing that we were proud of As
Americans and no longer is and it's
transparently political particularly
January 6 stuff there's like it's been
three years this is insane and so
someone at some point is going to be
like I don't know you're gonna have to
Ruby Ridge me because I'm not playing
along that's worrisome it is worse but
I'm saying like why does everyone why
does everyone pretend like this ghost
system which is merely sort of a you
know a a a gross grotesque imitation of
its former self still is real it's not
real you're speaking my language
everybody knows what two words I want to
say but I'll throw it to Charlie instead
no I mean look the Empire is going to
strike back in 24 what that looks like
we don't know and in in 20 they did
declare war that's what Co was Co was a
domestic declaration of war that gave
unelected bureaucrats unlimited power to
change the voting laws and they're going
to try to do it in 2024 probably a
foreign war but who knows and we have to
be prepared for that if we want even a
chance to win and people ask all the
time do you think we're going to win I I
have no idea well these rules are all
still in place yeah I mean mostly
universal mail and voting we've we've
minorly changed some things in Georgia
Wisconsin some things Arizona has gotten
worse actually we've gotten less secure
in our elections and also let's not kid
oursel there there's probably going to
be a s there's probably going to be a
false flag we're living through one
there's probably going to be an
agitation and and our reaction to the
next thing whatever that next thing is
is going to be critically important and
this is why I think there's such a
massive effort to take down Twitter to
take down Rumble to take away people's
ability to call out the scops in real
time which are happening right now and I
think the system is kind of scrambling
because I think they had a lot of things
down the pipeline but they know they
can't get away with it it's a very
dangerous Gambit that they're playing
right now and and I I don't see things
going well the longer this goes on and
the more that we don't know what the
future is going to be in in front of us
with as they're desperate that's what
waiting around is not the solution
because if we just petition them to hey
please stop electronic voting we can't
see the code please give us the code
it's not going to happen we need to
build systems that are better or in
parallel like we could vote legitimately
on the the machine or wherever with
paper and then on a blockchain
voluntarily like volun it would just
take a lot of us to do it and then we
could check and see if they're accurate
and that would be one way to move
forward it this is tough I mean I I
agree with what you're saying I agree
with what Tucker was saying yeah let's
not have electronic voting machines open
source the code do whatever you got to
do but there's a practical question of
what can we do right now with less than
a year in front of us the the best thing
is use x and Twitter because it's
obviously a threat to them they wouldn't
want to shut it down or go after Elon if
it wasn't working the greatest hope we
have in 2024 is we have a sliver of the
Public Square back that we didn't have
in 20 and that's why they're going to
try to either indict Elon or they're
just going to try to crash Twitter
through a DDOS attack or some sort of
foreign threat they're going to try to
take Twitter down by the summer the EU
is going after him now they just
announced thisday obviously no people
are saying things on Twitter that you're
not allowed to say and they're going
very viral very quickly and public
opinion is changing too rapidly can I
can I just point out I think it was Dave
Smith who pointed this out to us on the
show that before Elon Musk purchased X
if you said men are not women you would
be banned that that actually happened I
mean it is it is quite remarkable to be
fair the gains we've gotten back I mean
it's a tremendous loss for the fact that
we could not say on one of the biggest
social media Platforms in the world men
aren't women they actually banned Megan
Murphy for saying that just that it's
very innocuous I find Twitter is a is a
vulnerability at this moment the way
it's built the centralized system so if
we can decentralize that thing into a
protocol and still use it and it's fast
enough there's still issues with like
Noster where sending video is uh is slow
but it doesn't mean it's always going to
be slow we can use mesh networks so that
if we all have Twitter on our phone and
four of our phones go down the other two
are going to keep the network going I I
I do think that you know what Turning
Point USA is doing right here is one of
the most important things bringing
people together people are meeting each
other all throughout this building and
even in the streets even at restaurants
yes that culture building is the most
important thing because as we all know
it's been in quoted 50 billion times
Andrew bitart politics is Downstream
from culture someone told me this is
like the RNC now this is basically why
not just this is the RNC def fact
mhm that I I I I take that as a
compliment
if you might have meant it as an insult
would you call it the RNC Tucker it's
like NATO it sucks huge amounts of cash
and demands attention and does nothing
useful time to abolish it and it
subverts Poland uh in its um no I uh
yeah comparing anything to the
Republican National Committee or
convention is just it's an ugly SL it's
an ugly I'll take it as what the RNC
should be doct you know having been
around this stuff my whole life and
spent my whole off life in Washington
the true Corruption of the Republican
party I don't know it just took I was
like 10 years behind on that speak my
language but now that I now that I see
it I'm like I can't even believe this
exists Because by the way in some ways
it's more offensive than the Democratic
party because it's lying the Democratic
part is just like we're here to hurt you
and and belittle you of course but the
Republican Party pretends to be on your
side they're like quislings but they're
they're literally they they the
Republican Congress just allowed the
Administration to spy on Republican
voters so like is there a bigger sign of
the fact that they hate you every bit as
much as the Democrats what I love about
this though is I I agree with you
however if you are on the how would I
describe this the lower end of the IQ
bell curve you don't understand what it
is Democrats are saying they're doing so
for instance when they say they're going
to have uh free trade it's good for
everybody when they say we're going to
increase environmental regulations and
increase taxes to the average person
they're like this is good it makes the
rich pay their fair share but to anybody
who knows anything they they they
they're they're like hey wait a minute
this is going to drive all of our
manufacturing base overseas where they
can ship their products back for dirt
pay people in China dirt and have no
environmental regulations so this is why
Trump takes actions when he did in his
first term that resulted in a lot of
manufacturing coming back but see we can
understand that and I'm not trying to be
too much of a dick but there's a lot of
people who don't understand the basics
and I'm sorry but sometimes I do argue
with them on X and they say you know I I
remember one conversation where a guy
said you know food comes from the store
and I said yes but where does that food
come from he go what do you mean it
comes from the store and I said my God
help me I'll help you I was there for
that conversation I was like he's like
what do you mean milk's coming from the
store and I'm like there's a supply
chain I think you got to build trust and
it's challenging with someone you
disagree with but if they trust you
they're more willing to change their
mind about the things you're saying and
you mentioned Tucker about learning
about the corruption of the the
Republican party and I kind of watched
it in real time on TV in 2006 78 uh when
we were the Iraq War was kind of kind of
lit up and I remember you were into it
it seemed like you were on the side of
the Republican like George Bush and the
movement and then what John Stewart came
on one day and you guys just had it out
and it was like humiliation he's like
please stop harming America but the way
you were looking at him was like really
listening to him was that was that a
moment no I I thought and I still think
that he's a mediocrity and um and I
think time has proven me right on that
absolutely but what's interesting is
that by that point I mean this is not
even interesting at all actually but my
views on IR which I had I had a daily TV
show leading up to that war and I had
kind of endorsed it sort of
half-heartedly against my better
instincts but I did I did I did that
I've felt ashamed about it ever since
and then I went to Iraq in December of
2003 20 years ago this month and I got
through the day they captured Saddam at
to greet and I watched the whole place
fall apart and I won't bore you with the
details but I realized that everything
I'd advocated for was a complete lie
that this was a disaster that could only
hurt my country which is the only
country I really care about and by the
way it eliminated the entire Christian
population ofq which I guess we're not
allowed to say but if you're a Christian
you should care what happens to
Christians globally and I must say they
do bear the brunt of almost all of our
foreign policy and no one says that it's
happening now happened in Syria and it's
like shut up you're not allowed to
notice that why I'm a Christian and I
care about other Christians why wouldn't
I and they do wind up bearing the
disproportionate harm in our foreign
policy adventures and you have to ask
yourself why is that honestly what I
don't know the answer but it's super
evil well I I kind of I I feel like a
large component and I think you were
saying this earlier if not the component
of what uh uh the culture war is is the
destruction of Christianity of course
well yeah it exactly it's a destruction
of Christianity there's also a
destruction of Innocence Americans
unfortunately will look at our foreign
policy as if it's something entirely
removed from our cultural realities and
attitudes but the truth is we have
promoted a callous disregard for human
life over the course of decades because
abortion was legal Nationwide across
this country prior to the overturning of
row and if you think sending women the
message and Men the message that they
can wage war against their own unborn
children does not have effects on the
global stage and that a person who
doesn't have to care about the life of
their unborn child is supposed to care
about children in Gaza or Yemen you're
out of your mind yeah but unironically a
lot of these neocons um they're usually
pro-life even though they want to start
World War II and they want to send your
kids to fight a foreign war but that's
why they're pro-life they need more
babies to go send a war ex well
yes I I think that that's also a
component to but there's also a lot of
hypocrisy because a lot of the chaos
that was created by this foreign policy
was deliberate Dick Cheney in 1991 was
specifically talking about why we can't
get rid of Saddam Hussein because if we
do it's going to create chaos inside of
the Middle East it's going to kill the
Christians it's going to kill all the
different SE sectarian Muslims there
that are going to be fighting each other
it's going to make Iran more powerful in
the region it's going to create a vacuum
and they did it they knowingly did it
after notal the Republicans after 911
were on the wrong side of history and
they set up the institutions and the
apparatuses that are now going after
their other fellow Republicans and
putting them in jail and that's and that
and that's a hypocrisy that needs to be
called out and those people in that
party need to be purged that's right
there needs to be there need to be
consequences for the actions that
they've taken they have literally done
everything they could have possibly done
with the role that they had to destroy
our country and ensure that the people
do not have a prosperous future and what
happens I mean we put all of the
decision- making in the hands of people
who pay no price when they're wrong
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.net